- [Narrator] At least two federal agencies
are investigating Silicon Valley Bank
after it collapsed in March.
According to exclusive reporting
by the Wall Street Journal
Dave Michaels, a reporter
covering white collar crime
and financial enforcement at the Journal
breaks down what
investigators are probing.
(gentle suspenseful music)
- SVB fell victim to a bank run.
It was a bank run and
sort of the classic sense
where depositors all
sought their money back
at the same time, 42
billion worth of deposits
slow down of the bank on one date.
It's very common for
the Justice Department
and the Securities and Exchange
Commission to investigate
after a big public company or a bank fails
or any other kind of very
negative market event.
SVB Financial Group is a public company
who's shares are traded publicly
and it owned Silicon Valley Bank.
The SEC is likely to examine
what the public company said
about the risks to Silicon Valley Bank.
Did the public company disclose
all the facts and risks
that shareholders needed
in order to make informed
investment decisions?
The Justice Department can
look at a broader set of facts.
Their jurisdiction is not just limited
to capital markets or public companies
so it's likely that the DOJ
could be looking at matters
that are a little bit broader
than just how the, how
the public company worked.
Technically, DOJ and SEC
investigations are separate
but it is not unusual that
the two agencies cooperate.
In the end they make, you
know, separate decisions
sometimes on different timetables
about whether to bring
charges or civil claims.
The two agencies are
also, as we understand it,
looking at trades, stock sales
that the CEO and CFO of
the public company made
in close proximity to the bank's failure.
So about three weeks
before the bank failed
the CEO and the CFO sold in total
what amounts to about 2.7 or
$2.8 million worth of stock.
Anytime you see stock
sales in close proximity
to a very negative event,
it raises the suspicions
of a lot of people, including
regulators in law enforcement
and they are going to
look at the stock sales,
try to find out if the
executives had material,
non-public information, that
wasn't known to the market.
And if they had that, if they
were in possession of that,
then they weren't supposed to trade.
The Justice Department is conducting
as far as we know, a
criminal investigation.
The SEC is a civil regulatory agency
so its authority is limited
to fining companies,
civil penalties that is.
There isn't a timeframe that the SEC
or the DOJ have to stick to.
There is gonna be a period here
where the SEC is doing some investigations
whether they lead to any
lawsuits or claims of wrongdoing?
It's impossible to know at this point
and we might not know for a while.
(melancholic music)